welcome back to the david pakman show
i'm fair and cousins sitting in for
david pakman this week let's get right
back to more news and uh what happened
on monday
was it was revealed that donald trump is
suing
new york attorney general leticia james
to get the investigation into his
company
shut
down
trump's lawyers
in their filing
argued quote
the
was politically motivated
and the mission is guided solely by
political animus and a desire to harass
intimidate and retaliate against a
private citizen who she views
as a political opponent she of course
being new york attorney general leticia
james
this is
without a doubt
in my non-lawyer expert opinion
one of the dumbest legal arguments i've
honestly ever seen
this investigation has already resulted
in criminal charges criminal charges
against both the trump organization
for tax crimes
and cfo alan weisselberg
so how on earth
are you going to go to court
in front of a judge and say judge listen
up
you know this investigation that is
going to put our cfo in jail and
causing us some legal headaches with the
organization well it's politically
motivated
the judge is going to look at that and
say but
but there's there's criminal charges
like it's
it's bore fruit
right we we have actual results
from this criminal investigation that
show criminal wrongdoing
so how are you going to sit there and
tell me
that this is a witch hunt when we've
found
witches you know
i mentioned this
over on my channel fair and balanced
um donald trump might actually have a
pretty good case
for legal malpractice at this point
that's how bad this argument is
now here's the thing
if this investigation which of course
has been going on for about two years
if it was going on for two years
and they couldn't find any evidence of
criminal wrongdoing you may have a very
slim chance of being successful with
this particular argument right
you know if you're looking at something
for two years and still can't find
anything at all you've poured through
the documents you've had the depositions
and you have nothing
then that's a good sign most likely that
there's nothing there
but there is a there there's there's a
there there
and there is that there have been
criminal charges on tax related
uh uh
i guess you would call them activities
so you can't say that this is purely a
political motivated stunt
when you got a guy that's probably going
to jail for this
so the question comes down to timing
right
why
at any point in the past two years
donald trump could have filed this
ridiculous lawsuit
and said you're coming after me because
i'm president you're a democrat you hate
me and blah blah blah
he could have filed the lawsuit after
the charges were filed against cfo allen
weisselberg and of course the trump
organization itself was also indicted
but he didn't
he waited until now
so
now we get to put on our speculator
glasses
and try to figure out why
my best guess
and again this is just my hypothesis
is that there's something big coming
down the pipeline
why wait till now
probably because you know something
as we know
they've gotten a hold of donald trump's
financial documents
we have seen that this investigation
seems to span beyond the state of new
york at the moment you know there's
incidents in chicago that are now also
being reviewed you've got some actually
also happening up in rochester new york
all of it centering around the same
thing did trump and his organization
lie about the value of their properties
to both tax authorities
and the banks
was it tax fraud or was it bank fraud or
maybe was it a little bit of both
that's what they're looking at up in
westchester
that's what they're looking at over in
chicago and that's what they're looking
at in new york
bunch of different trump-owned
properties that are all being
investigated for the same thing and with
what's happening in westchester for the
record
they've got the proof
they've got his presidential filings
where he showed the property was worth
one thing they've got the local tax
records where he claimed it's worth
something far less than what he claimed
on his
financial disclosure forms
so maybe that's what it is
maybe the walls are closing in a little
too quickly for him
maybe there's too many investigations
going on and he's doing what he can to
file this ridiculous lawsuit
to maybe stall it a little bit
because at best that's all he's going to
do
this is not going to get this lawsuit
thrown out of court
but it may slow it down a bit
it may allow for
a little bit of appeal here and there
it's going to get tossed out of every
court it goes in front of that's a given
again because the argument is very
stupid
but it may be just enough for trump
to delay it enough to maybe come up with
a decent legal argument
for when things finally go totally
sideways
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 percent
off a subscription
go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below